[Music]
all right bill forza horizon for out now
on pc it's obviously a huge open world
half arkady half sim driving game which
opens up comparisons to the crew - which
launched earlier on this year we've both
been playing a bunch of forza and have
played a bunch of the crew - when it
comes to the world which i think is the
most striking thing about each of them
obviously you've got USA in the crew -
in the UK or britain more specifically
in forza how do you think those two
worlds compare i guess the biggest
difference straight away is the size so
the crew - being set in the united
states a massive country and it is a
massive map compared to forza horizon
the falls britain which is less of a
sort of imitation of the actual place
but more of a best hits highlights of
parts of Britain and for me the main
difference is that trying to make such a
big map it spread a bit thin
whereas in Forza horizon it's it's small
but it's very detailed and for me it
just feels more like a real place
[Music]
yeah now I groovy it kind of has the the
themes and the look of britain without
really like london isn't in the map you
know and it's like there's there's no of
like well I think Edinburgh is in there
isn't it Edinburgh is the big city yeah
yeah but parts of the latest Lake
District and northern England yeah but
we can tell is that there aren't so many
whereas like in the crew two you've got
New York and Las Vegas and Los Angeles
and there are like the landmarks in
there which the Forza doesn't do quite
so much of but why then does Forza feel
more of a detail world to you what what
is it about that world that makes it
feel more detailed and more real it's
all I had a very emotional reaction to
this game just playing it because
obviously we are from Britain and I grew
up driving around country lanes that
feel very similar to what's in the
horizon for so it does feel more life
like a more alive than the crew two's
USA which is massive
and it's very cool how it has a
real-time map in the degree to so you
can be driving your car and zoom out and
slowly zoom out and zoom out and zoom
out and it's like a real-time map and
you can go and drop and say I want to go
to New York and then you're just
instantly in New York City hmm and it
zooms in on the map and you can see your
car in Times Square for example so it's
like you're actually sightseeing the
u.s. however there's something about it
that just doesn't feel real it kind of
feels to me like a museum or like a
gallery you know everything sort of web
set up for you to look at rather than
really being able to interact with I
think forces world enables you to go
fast
it sort of encourages speed and a little
bit reckless driving which is fun hmm
and this isn't just something from the
crew too but in that game when you hit a
wall if does feel like you do stop solid
whereas in Forza it's a lot more
forgiving and I've actually quite fun to
just drift around a corner of a country
lane and take out a few bricks from a
wall smash down a fence and you can get
away with a lot more than you can in not
just the crew - I suppose but in a lot
of other racing games
[Music]
400 meters left
and the crew to be fair we talk about
cities a lot because they in our mind
stories like the big parts of it but
there are some really cool elements as
well like there's a lot to uncover but I
don't think the game really helps you
find them so it was like I want to go to
the Grand Canyon not being from America
I can't pinpoint it straight away I know
roughly where it is so I'm like zooming
in and looking for it and yeah if you
find the right place on that it's there
from the very little that I played the
crew to doesn't build hugely on what was
already there in the first one it's you
know it's just America again right yeah
whereas obviously with Forza it's a
completely different setting you've gone
from who's Australia wasn't it young
horizon three you've gone from Australia
to Britain which is hugely different
landscape hugely different art style
aesthetic and hugely different roads to
race on really and of course we got the
seasons yeah totally changed the map
yeah and I think that that scene is a
bit of a gimmick or like something you
know you read in the marketing like it's
got four seasons we've seen we've seen
different weather and times of year in
games before but actually the way the
game works and progresses and you get to
a point where it does start shifting
week to week on seasons it really does
change the map yeah actually don't you
and actually you know it's like our
winter that's not going to be as nice as
summer but actually it looks stunning
and feels amazing to drive around
because you're just drifting around no
snowy mountains and icy roads and you're
like oh that Lake is frozen though so
now I'm gonna drive on it so that
actually two Falls right and pours
credit does do a lot to make even though
it's a smaller map it freshens it up and
more often than you think yeah and of
course Forza wins this round because
it's got roundabouts in it and any game
that has roundabouts and it earns my
vote
take the second exit
of course the important thing in a
driving game bill is how they feel to
cars yeah the cars themselves right in
your opinion which which game feels
better do you think because in my mind
like Forza I don't think the crew who
feels bad but Forza at least in mice of
more casual focused mind I would say
force of feels more satisfying to
actually drive the car in the Crito is
definitely more arcadey mmm Forza
horizon is still an arcade driving game
but you can definitely feel the sort of
heritage of its driving the sim
background with Forza Motorsport but
yeah I guess big difference is driving
wise the crew too has boost so you have
nitrous or nitrate and I did miss that
in Forza I was like oh I'm going to
press X to boost honor I can't so that
is fun that is fun to do see I I don't I
don't find the boost in the crew to that
fun it doesn't feel as fast as it should
I suppose what the crew - doesn't have
which force it does is rewind yeah
massive I think every modern racing game
should have rewind mainly because it
just shows that the game respects your
time as a player yeah there are so many
times when you have been right at the
end of a race and you crash you make a
stupid mistake and yes
that could be the players fault but it
means you've lost that whole races
progress a lot of the time whereas Forza
has rewind
[Applause]
with the crew too you can change into
you can magically warp into a plane or a
boat how did those two types of vehicles
feel to you in the crew initially I'll
be honest I did write them off fast like
it's a racing game but racing boats and
planes isn't fun for me at least I'm
more of a car person I love cars and I
want to get my Nissan GTR and drive
around the world like I want to drive my
favorite cars but actually once I
started using those and realizing how
quickly you can switch between the three
main types I was having a lot of fun and
I was finding scenarios that you can
have in the crew too that are unrivaled
you can't do in any other game so I
could be driving my car through Times
Square and then I go off a ramp
transform into a plane fly around the
Empire State Building and then drop into
the water transform into a speedboat and
then drive around the Statue of Liberty
and that is a really cool moment that
you can do all around the map and you
can just decide like I'm bit bored of
driving a much fly so the crew takes
credit that is really cool yeah and at
that moment where you switch it is
impressive yeah yes feel cool to
suddenly like you say switch into a
completely different vehicle type and
suddenly you're flying through the air
or you know swimming through the sea
that is cool but what I would say is
that especially the boat I don't find a
boat satisfying at all I find the boat
it's really like lethargic and like like
you've like you're driving through
treacle or something I don't know I just
really don't find it fun the planes I
think are actually surprisingly fun I
was the same as you I sort of initially
wrote them off and then you get into a
plane and actually it's quite fun to
control pain thing with the crew too is
that it feels almost like Oh compare it
to an all-you-can-eat buffet yeah it's
like you have all this selection and all
this choice of different types of racing
events and you know you can do rally or
Street races or and that's before you
even get onto the planes and the boats
everything there's so much choice and so
much selection it's constantly
bombarding you with things to do like
hey look at this race you can do Hey
look at this place you can discover and
that's great but it's all to distract
you from the fact that none of it is
actually in my opinion that great and
obviously then you've got enforcer
the equivalent of the the changing
vehicles thing is the fact that you've
got the different seasons which and we
touched on them earlier but you that
does change the way the game feels right
absolutely and like you know if it's if
it's snowy is massively different to
handle a car in that weather or if it's
raining or whatever than if it's dry in
your on tarmac yeah another thing that
both games have in Forza horizon its
showcases the crew to does have a
similar event but it's like we're
showing off what this game can do in
Forza horizon it's the showcase events
so you might race a hovercraft or you
might race a train to Edinburgh you're
saying to me like you love Top Gear like
the old Top Gear where they would have
those races against like people or a
bullet train yeah and it feels like it's
that but the video game version yeah and
they are amazing they are a real
spectacle the crew too has events where
you have to use all three boat plane car
but it just feels like you're chasing
checkpoints it never really feels as
amazing as it doesn't force a horizon
yeah
so having settled that bill if I've got
$60 40 pounds in my pocket which game do
you think I should go out and buy
honestly I think it's Forza horizon 4
it just feels very very refined and fun
to play it just feels like a world I
want to explore not just because it's
the Great Britain and I live here and
it's very nostalgic but it just feels
like the better experience yeah
absolutely and it's got roundabouts
right which is the I think we can all
agree on that
yeah whereas the crew - you know I don't
want to completely right off because it
it does still have its merits right and
obviously Forza is the console exclusive
so for anyone who doesn't have an Xbox
one or a PC you know the crew - is still
a worthy addition there were a lot of
fun yeah and you have planes and boats
and hovercrafts and motorbikes and
there's a lot of variety there and you
can still have a lot of fun in that
world especially if you go online with a
bunch of mates you just go exploring and
find fun things to do
[Music]
alright guys thanks for watching that
was our take on Forza horizon 4 verses
the crew - let's not you think on the 2
games in the comment section below or
you can come and yell at us on Twitter
I'm at dare said I'm the Quivers dead
remember to watch verses every Thursday
on GameSpot drive safe
I know that's the worst I liked it
[Music]
you